let's do some more involved examples
using decimals so let's say we want to
add four and twenty two hundredths to 61
and 37 hundredths like always I
encourage you to pause the video and try
to figure out on your own well the way
that my brain tries to tackle it is it
says all right I have four and twenty
261 and thirty seven hundredths how
about I add the four plus the sixty one
so it's going to be four plus sixty one
and then separately let me add the
twenty two hundredths to the 37
hundredths so then I'm going to add 22
hundredths plus 37 hundredths and so
four plus sixty one is going to be equal
to 65 and then 22 hundredths plus 37
hundredths well what's 22 plus 37 let's
see 20 plus 30 is 50 and then 2 plus 7
is 9 and so it's going to be 59
hundredths so 59 hundredths this is
going to be 65 and 59 hundredths which
we can write as 65 and fifty nine
hundredths
now like I've mentioned in previous
videos there's many different ways of
adding decimals and in future videos
we'll learn arguably faster ways of
doing it but I want to show you multiple
ways so you get a sense of at least ways
to approach it and this is the way that
I do it in my head if someone said hey
something cost sixty one dollars
thirty-seven cents and then you had to
pay four dollars and twenty to two cents
in tax how much did you have to pay in
total this is how I would actually do it
in my head I would get sixty five
dollars and fifty nine cents
let's do let's do another example so
let's say that we have three and fifty
three hundredths and we want to add that
to 4 and seventy-two hundredths like
always pause this video and see if you
figure it out on your own so like we did
in the previous example we could say all
right we could add the ones three ones
plus four ones so it's going to be three
plus four and then we could add the
hundreds and we could say plus fifty
three hundredths plus fifty three
hundredths plus seventy two hundredths
plus seventy two hundredths now the
three plus four is pretty
straightforward that's just going to be
the blue color this is just going to be
equal to seven but what is 53 hundredths
plus 72 hundredths
well what's 52 what what's 53 plus 72
well three plus two right this way this
is 53 hundreds hundreds and this is
seventy-two hundredths well three plus
two is going to be equal to 5 and then
fifty plus seventy is equal to 120 so
this is going to be 125 hundredths 125
hundredths so how do we write one
hundred and twenty-five hundredths as a
decimal or as just well this is a number
well there's a couple of ways to think
about it you could view this as 100
hundredths hundredths plus 25 hundredths
plus 25 hundredths and the reason why I
picked a hundred hundredths is because
one hundred hundreds make a whole plus
25 hundredths and so 100 hundredths is
just going to be one so there's going to
be one plus 25 hundredths so I could
write this 1 plus 0.25 and remember I'm
adding that to the 7-year so it's going
to be 7 plus the 1 plus the 25
hundredths so when we added the 53
hundred plus the seventy-two hundredths
we get 125 hundredths which is the same
thing as one and twenty-five hundred
now the one we could add in the ones to
the other ones and so this is going to
be 7 plus 1 is equal to 8 8 and 25
hundredths so 8.25 now I'm going to
introduce you a little bit to how people
might tackle this more systematically
and I want you to think about how this
is the exact same thing that we just did
so what you're going to see in the
future is people are say ok line up the
decimals so three point five three plus
four point seven two the reason why
people say line up the decimals is so
that you're adding the right places to
the right places for point seven two and
then they say all right well let's go
place by place and add it up which is
essentially what we just did without
doing it as as organized of a way here
and I did it this way so that you really
get the understanding of what's going on
but you could say all right I have three
hundredths plus two hundredths so I'm
adding in the hundredths place so three
hundreds plus two hundredths is five
hundredths and then you could say okay
then I have 50 hundredths plus 70
hundredths which I did over here or you
could view this as five tenths plus
seven tenths and five tenths and seven
tenths is going to be equal to twelve
tenths but you can't write 12 tenths in
the tenths place but what you can do so
you can't write so five plus seven is
going to be twelve tenths but twelve
tenths is the same thing as 1 & 2 tenths
so you can write the two tenths in the
tenths place and then you take the 1 and
you put it in the ones place so five
tenths plus seven tenths is one and two
tenths and then you add the ones up and
so you get one plus three plus four is
eight so it's eight and two tenths and
five hundredths or eight and 25
hundredths or 8.25 the exact same thing
any way that you try to tackle it but
hopefully it makes sense what's actually
going on you're adding 100 your ending
100 to 110 stew tenths ones two ones and
when you say you add ten to ten
and you get something that's larger than
one well that part that that is a whole
number you can put in the ones place and
we'll get much much more practice with
this in future videos